welcome to this video playing from 2z
fantasy let's see Igor deeply yeah I
think I've played him before with a draw
so we get the so called English hence
the e6b 6 defense get a Queen's Indian
flavor but we still have f5 available
and black shirt should use this resource
of course its own perfectly okay for
white as well very solid so I go nitey
for quickly intending to take on c3
probably will cover the night somehow so
that you can keep a spawn structure
intact hmm and they are like this earned
for example so let's see there should be
seven f6 is very often a good idea now
maybe take take now
and Bishop f6 next now so black has some
two bishops on the long diagonal cannot
go d5 because of this pin and term here
an interesting question it looks quite
tempting to play c5 here is this good it
probably has to reply you three but it's
a very it's very very committal maybe
just a complete development Nazi 67
there's another typical way to play um I
could take d4 here should i do that 94
94 Bishop g2 kingi to c5 winning winning
it back but damn it's probably only a
slightly worse structure at the end yeah
so I want to keep the sale on the board
should i do this year maybe it's often a
good idea occupying the central square
with the bishop and then decide how to
set up the pawn structure yeah this is a
way for white to trying to use this this
bishop on your form as a target I mean
like 92 and then I'm going back okay so
interesting can I do this and maybe play
a phony form that's a risky maybe
yeah if I that's that's an interesting
moment here I can have f4 or i also have
c5 p.m. this kind of a text c5 and then
probably five being played c5 if I takes
on d for 2495 rookie 5d6 maybe maybe
winning material in five is also a movie
5
difficult spend lots of time here that's
interesting if he takes both captures
are interesting and ef5 I take on d4 or
Bishop f5 I take on d4 leading to a very
yeah a very unique position maybe you
can go d5 but i don't think that EF f
takes e4 can be can be a big problem not
probably not
hmm not sure what one should do maybe
maybe Bishop f5 oh this this I didn't
consider interesting move though gets in
the Queen c4 idea Quincy for check okay
let's let's just play a practical
decision here not falling much more
behind on the clock it's already already
critical at the time no that's not
that's not too brilliant it's got
seasick Sam no that's not that's not a
very nice position maybe it is some
maybe it is still playable that's not
looking very good c5 are strong i didn't
see that it's a kind of move once you
have it on the board you instantly see
that okay this is a problem but still
you can easily overlook it at least I
did okay should it take now on d6 or
place using c6 and it's maybe not so
good yeah well maybe I can play 97
putting some pressure on d5
unclear unclear to me how I should set
up my my pieces maybe be five will be
six the way to activate yeah I need I
need this counter play on d5 badly i
know i can take or not should be five
let's take it and ask questions 2
questions later
yeah still bad structure still a bad
structure wanted to try to to time
learning my structure you maybe get
something to see for but it didn't
really work so you can just play before
and that's not really great b5 hangs
takes rook takes this may be a pin I
have a very suspicious very suspicious
back rank always
not great trying to get a counter play
with night see form and I really must
must make sure that i'm not back ranked
mated night b5 rook c8 trying to try to
hold on I probably won't take but I can
enter this as a primo anyway and
whoopsie 294 is my mouth and I can take
care of it I need to I need the counter
plane which might not be enough but i
need some some hope that I get the ape
or maybe
they can just take it I'm said I'm so
stupid sometimes and then made ah it was
probably lost anyway but yeah like this
okay black resemble to us a tour stupid
in any case of course but maybe I can
somehow like least continue yeah root
beer heads the lost its still lost
because of my bad King positioners wrong
I had some hope after getting getting
day porn but probably he's just too
quick as Janet still lost yeah the c5
move was was very strong this was very
strong I mean here I had alternatives if
I've just looked looked interesting but
yeah this is a good room fly really yeah
maybe I should take on the form very
very complicated I was surprised Quincy
seven looked like a mistake to me but
it's still it so keeps this edge I have
no no count to play whatsoever now so e5
was a most probably a bad a bad decision
maybe c5 yeah there were many
alternatives along the way yeah and
always this is also always this c5 idea
maybe I should do this now while III is
not possible
yeah very difficult and can play all
kinds of stuff him but yet say it's
already a bit a bit tricky my original
idea was f4 of course but it's not clear
that this is any good I am probably not
yeah this is really problematic after c5
you played that well what can you do ok
thanks for watching